hello everyone uh i'm alana i'm a very
very very big batman fan and i was at
gdc last week the game developers
conference meaning that i kind of missed
a bunch of stuff and it turns out there
is a batman
the batman that is um joker deleted
scene i saw a couple of whispers about
this on twitter but um have not seen any
of it and from what i can tell i'm
watching this on movie trailer source
it's five minutes long i was not
expecting that when they said deleted
scene i still expected it to be like a
teaser like i expected that this was
something that was made for marketing
and then called a deleted scene later
five whole minutes probably an authentic
deleted scene so i'm really excited to
watch it um i will say
my reaction to joker when watching the
batman was largely negative i i didn't
love the look of it i think i was irked
by the fact that they were just casually
letting two criminally insane inmates
chat and watch the news
just seemed like a bit of an oversight
on our um arkham asylum part there
um
but i'm happy to be wrong because i know
that he's a very talented actor and i
hope this is good i'm curious um so
let's do it
this is the batman joker deleted scene
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are good
is the implication that he
talks to
joker before talking arila
oh after i guess
present
oh anniversary isn't it
there's a serial killing
oh he like visits it
because he already locked him up of
course
first
anniversary is paper
what makes you think i'm so cheap
i thought you'd be curious
hmm
don't you
you have pictures
i'm having trouble hearing him a little
bit
interesting how like aesthetically
zombie-ish they made him
do you think that he's gonna finally
suggest that somebody goes and checks
where the um
where the photos were taken from i found
that so weird they
the photos that riddler leaks to the
press are taken from his apartment
nobody goes and checks
okay sorry
he likes little puzzles doesn't he
so ridiculous
like you've been planning this his whole
life
i know who he is
oh
[Music]
who is he
he's a nobody
wants to be somebody
you think his motive is political oh no
this is very very personal
hmm
he feels these people have all along him
probably goes way back
unhealed wounds stolen much money
was right she writing to me
maybe
he's a fan of yours
he's also right
or maybe he's got a grudge against you
too
maybe you're the main course
any theories
amazing both of those things are correct
that's that's smart writing i'm normally
so happy
but something is different
this time
this is very upsetting to you let's get
back to him why
you are so much more fun to talk about
me what are you here to talk about i
want to know how he thinks you know
exactly how he thinks have you read this
file
you two have so much in common
masked adventures
interesting
okay
i'll tell you what i really think
i
think you don't really care about his
motives with any loves or hates you
i think somewhere deep down
you're just
[Applause]
don't
terrified
you think they deserved it
you think they deserved it
[Applause]
interesting
the way he looks is very um
arkham city
but obviously a very different
joker um
i love that they didn't have him in full
focus until the very end there
that was cool um yeah very different
joker
difficult to really grasp who that
character actually is like what does he
try to be a psychiatrist he's trying to
like psychoanalyze people
it's like some harley vibes there um
i like the writing in that scene and
what it like actually foretells about
what the riddler was actually thinking
because i guess they would have placed
this a little bit sooner also would have
been an intro to arkham asylum like i
like the way it leads into the plot it's
an interesting choice to cut it i wonder
if maybe they felt like it it gave too
much away
i liked his performance too so i thought
he
was compelling to watch
um which yeah i didn't like him in the
end of the movie but i liked him in this
scene so
interesting choice to release it i
assume it wasn't a leak i actually don't
know
um
[Music]
yeah
i liked it
i'm trying to find the shot where he's
actually kind of more in focus there
i wonder
what they're trying to lean into with
that
hmm
i also love
batman going to joker who he has locked
up presumably
um because he can't help himself
like it's one of my favorite
batman arks ever which is one of my
favorite batman themes ever is the
obsession with joker and vice versa
um
i think arkham origins if you haven't
played it does a really good job of
exploring their relationship it's a lot
of people's least favorite arkham game
but it does such a good job of exploring
their relationship and there's this one
frame i think it's from death in the
family that i always really loved where
i'm pretty sure it is uh
batman
goes to see joker locked up and takes
the cow off and shows him that he's
bruce and joker just stares at him
like it was this whole fake game about
caring who was under the mask it was
never real it's like he completely
disassociates and never actually
acknowledges it
love their relationship love the hint of
that there um let's read some some
comments shall we
see how the internet
felt pull this over a little bit
[Music]
masterfully done in just a five minute
clip see how sadistic yet intelligent
this joker is agreed that he seems very
intelligent
and how great of a threat batman sees
him as his deformed and evil looking
appearance also matches this dark
version of gotham as well
i wish this was in the movie as it sets
up the interaction with the riddler
especially the nobody part i agree with
that i do like what it does for riddler
really love how they never give us a
full look at joker only small close-ups
to certain parts of his face giving us
an idea of what he'll he will look like
while still sorry what he looks like
while still giving a sense of mystery to
the character
i really hope they do this for the next
movie maybe having scarecrow mr breeze
is the next villain
and with each appearance of joker
leading up to the third movie we see
more and more of his appearance hmm
that's a good idea
the dynamic between the two is
interesting agreed it's clear that
batman sees joker as a disfigured
kindred spirit he values and consults
the joker's opinion not
as one reveals that of his slasher
superior kind of like clary starling's
relationship with hannibal lecter he
respects the intellect of his equal his
enemy
this person's trying to get real poetic
with this comet he has more in common
with his arch nemesis and the people
he's protecting and showing the joker
knows that batman is no boy he's capable
of becoming a villain
i love this die hard joker fan here
oh yeah injustice that's not a bad call
yeah the hannibal to clarisse is the
correct goal
seems like people really liked it
heath was a major inspiration in the
voice in some of the mannerisms i didn't
feel that so much
obviously a little bit but
not a ton
didn't think i would like this but it
fits perfectly agreed it feels like it
fits very well
as much as i'd have loved to have seen
this deleted scene in the movie i think
it almost works better as a teaser makes
you want more solidly done nightmarish
also agreed it does work very well as a
teaser
yeah i wonder why they took it out i
also wonder if this means that there
will be um
a director's cut at some point or if
we'll get more footage like what else
they removed from the movie because it's
obviously a very long movie i can't
imagine they removed that much but maybe
um i really like this
i thought it was great
yeah that's my review
alright bye everyone